you've mentioned the lunar program let
me ask you about that yeah um there's uh
a lot going on there and you haven't
really talked about it much so in
addition to the Artemis program with
NASA uh blue is doing its own Lander
program can you describe it uh there's a
there's a sexy picture on Instagram with
with one of them is it the MK1 I guess
yeah the mark one the picture is me with
Bill Nelson the NASA administrator just
a clarify the Lander is the sexy thing
about
the really want clarify I know it's not
me I know it was either you the Lander
or Bill okay
um I love clarifying okay um the uh yes
the Maran Lander um is designed to take
3,000 kilogram to the surface of the
Moon a cargo Expendable cargo it's an
Expendable Lander lands on the moon
stays there take 3,000 kg to the surface
it can be launched on a single new Glenn
flight which is very important so it's a
relatively simple architecture just like
the human Landing system Lander called
the mark 2 Mark 1 is also uh fueled with
liquid
hydrogen and uh which is for for high
energy missions like landing on the
surface of the Moon the high specific
impulse of hydrogen is a very big
Advantage the disadvantage of hydrogen
has always been that it's uh since it's
such a deep cryogen it's not storable so
it's constantly boiling off and you're
losing propellant um because it's
boiling off and so what we're doing is
part of the L of our lunar program is
developing solar powered cryocoolers
that can actually make hydrogen a
storable propellant for deep space and
that's a real gamech Cher uh it's a game
Cher for any high energy Mission so to
the the moon but to the outer planets to
Mars everywhere so the idea with Mark
one both Mark 1 and Mark I is the new
Glen
can uh carry it from the surface of
Earth to the surface
of the Moon exactly so the Mark 1 is
Expendable the lunar the lunar lander
we're developing for NASA the mark two
Lander that's part of uh the emis they
call it the sustaining Lander program so
that Lander is designed to be
reusable it can land on the surface of
the Moon in in a single stage
configuration and then take off so the
whole the you know the if you look at
the Apollo
program the lunarlander and Apollo was
really two stages it would land on the
surface and then it would leave The
Descent stage on the surface of the Moon
and only the absent stage would go back
up into lunar orbit where it would
Rendevous with the Command Module here
what we're doing is we have a single
stage lunar lander that carries down
enough propellant so that it can bring
the whole thing back up so that it can
be reused over and over and the point of
doing that of course is to reduce cost
so that you can make Lunar missions more
affordable over time which is that's one
of NASA's big objectives because this
time the the whole point of Artimus is
go back to the moon but this time to
stay so you know back in the Apollo
program we went to the moon six times
and then ended the program and it really
was too expensive to to continue and so
there's a few questions there but one is
how do you stay on the moon what what
ideas do you have
about uh yeah like a sustain sustaining
life where a few folks can stay there
for prolong periods of time well um one
of the things we're working on is um use
using lunar resources like lunar
regolith to
manufacture Commodities and even solar
cells on the surface of the Moon we've
already built a solar cell that is
completely made from lunar reguli
simulant and this solar cell is only
about 7% uh power efficient so it's very
inefficient compared to you know the
more advanced solar cells that we make
here on Earth but if you can figure out
how to make a practical solar cell
Factory that you can land on the surface
of the Moon and then the raw material
for those solar cells is simply lunar
regolith then you can just uh you know
continue to churn out solar cells on the
surface of the Moon have lots of power
on the surface of the Moon that will
make it easier for people to live on the
moon uh similarly we're working on
extracting oxygen from from lunar
regolith so lunar regolith by weight is
has a lot of oxygen in it it's bound
very tightly you know in as oxides with
other elements and so it you have to
separate the oxygen which is very energy
intensive so that also could work
together with the uh solar cells but if
you can uh and then
ultimately we may be able to find
practical
quantities of ice in the permanently
shadowed craters on the poles of the
Moon and we know there is ice water um
in those uh or water ice in those
craters and we know that we can break
that down uh with electrolysis into
hydrogen and oxygen and then you'd not
only have oxygen but you'd also have a
very good high efficiency propellant uh
Fuel and in hydrogen so there's a lot
there's a lot we can do to make the moon
more sustainable over time but the very
first step the thing the kind of gate
that all of that has to go through is we
need to be able to
land uh cargo and humans on the surface
of the Moon at an acceptable cost to
fast forward a little bit is there any
chance Jeff basil steps foot on the moon
and on
Mars one or the other or both it's very
unlikely I think it's probably something
that gets done by Future Generations by
the time it gets to me I think in my
lifetime that's probably going to be
done by professional astronauts sadly I
would love to sign up for that mission
um so don't count me out yet Lex you
know give me give me a fighting shot
here maybe but I think if we're if we
are uh
placing uh reasonable bets on such a
thing in my lifetime that will continue
to be done by professional astronauts
yeah so these are risky difficult
missions and probably missions that
require a lot of training you know you
are going there for a very specific
purpose to do something we're going to
be able to do a lot on the Moon too with
automation so you know in terms of
setting up these factories and doing all
that we we're sophisticated enough now
with automation that we probably don't
need humans to tend those factories and
machines um so it's there's a lot that's
going to be done in both
modes